- So Kelly, we have
several different options
on what type of browser we use.
Does it matter from a safety
and privacy point of view?
- Yeah, there are a
couple factors that you
might wanna think about that make
a browser potentially safer.
So one thing that's
important is how frequently
the browser updates and
ideally automatically updates.
So attackers are constantly
looking for gaps and holes where
they can press their advantage.
And browser manufacturers
should be looking to
close those gaps and protect your computer
by releasing updates with
security updates in them.
Another thing you might
wanna consider is what built
in security protections your browser has.
So browsers like Chrome, use
my team service safe browsing
to offer malware, phishing,
unwanted software protections.
And so that's basically
your first line of defense.
We'll be looking out for
you to see if there is
a dangerous site and warn
you about it so you have that
before it even touches your computer.
There are also other things
like Chrome has protections
against dangerous extensions
that are offered, as well
as things like feature
that looks for passwords
that might have been
leaked, so you know that you
can update your password.
So thinking about what does
your browser offer in terms
of built in security protections
can be an important role
as well.
- Super useful.